when I was 12 years old the summer
before my 13th birthday I touched my
younger sister who was 8 and and when I
say touched I touched her my skin made
contact with her vagina my mom called a
Christian counselor and wanted to get
help and then at the end of the call
said well required by law to report all
this information over to Child
Protective Services
the next day I was arrested and that
began three and a half years of
incarceration
and I got out when I was 17
today I was hosting my very first
sex-offender brunch I invited a couple
of guys on the registry and I wanted
them to meet my friends in the press not
because I am pro sex offender but
because there are so many people with
this label sex offender who pose no
threat to children whatsoever and I
wanted the public to start realizing
that I find that when people get to know
you
they're fundamentally challenge in this
identity they have of the sex offender
which is defined by what they've seen in
law and order and this person used like
a regular preppy gay white kid that they
went to prep school with I became
comfortable with myself
and so when I realized who I was and
society could not define who I was I'm
comfortable meeting anybody
I got out after three and a half years
and then lived life outside on parole
when I was 21 and also on the registry
so then I go to high school within a few
weeks after being released from prison
I'm on the prom committee I'm an officer
of my class which is really interesting
when you think about how that was
possible Google Google didn't exist back
then which is you know we were using Ask
Jeeves and it's like it's you know very
hard to type in is josh graven a sex
offender at the time so so you flash
forward and some mom saw this guy who
was at the time the senior class
president and you know the the in the
yearbook i was my class most friendliest
person or something along those lines
and well anyway so the last two weeks of
my high school experience and to say
that I love schools probably an
understatement was spinnin shame because
all of a sudden people that I had eaten
lunch with would no longer sit at the
table with me teachers who had actively
lobbied to try to get me on the academic
teams would no longer even acknowledge
that I existed so I go to college I
don't know how many of you are familiar
with journalism or what a slow news day
is but in Lubbock Texas a slow news day
might cause a local journalist to look
at the registry so without my permission
or without consulting me
a journalist ran my profile ran a
picture that I was living at on Texas
Tech University and at any rate all of a
sudden death threats were slid under my
door I lived on the dorm at this time I
was the dorm president and so I didn't
come out of my room for two months I
didn't want to talk to anybody and I
definitely didn't want to talk to the
police because the police once they get
it once they get involved in a case like
mine the issue transitions from them
protecting me to me being investigated
got married and then I had kids and then
all of a sudden you have something I did
as a 12 year old that barred me from
dropping off my kids at school or
picking them up all of a sudden or
volunteering or seeing anything they
were going to lunch anything you might
normally do as a parent so you know it's
just it's interesting when you think
about we have a juvenile system right
but when you're talking about sex
offenses for some reason this concept of
juvenile ism or being a youth or a child
is just thrown out the window when I was
19 I went to prison for was supposed to
be had been six-and-a-half years for
having a consensual relationship with a
high school age kid he was 14 and a half
he was someone I had known for a while
it was really close to so I got to my
release date and they just didn't let me
out they served me with a petition
trying to label me a sexually violent
predator and it took two and a half
years past my mandatory prison release
date to even get a trial i sat in
solitary confinement all that time which
meant that altogether I served four and
a half of my nine years behind bars in
solitary what these laws are designed to
do is essentially impose a secondary
prison sentence
and while Galen got out this is in
Virginia
how many people are there on civil
commitment now right now there are about
368 people that are simply punitive
Virginia are we talking about the whole
idea that people are sex offenders is
completely misconstrued whether it's a
case like ours or a really truly
egregious case the policies that we have
in effect are not working ninety five
percent of people in prison come home
and so then
as a registrant I cannot get food stamps
they cannot live in section 8 I cannot
get any assistance or housing or jobs
and we keep driving them down in the
ground and so you know the world is no
safer for it the vast majority of child
sexual abuse is committed by somebody
who's known to the offender usually it's
a family member or a close friend and
this is 95% of child sexual abuse right
it's not being committed by somebody
that's ever been convicted of something
so if we actually care about protecting
our kids we're missing the opportunity
to do that by focusing on marginalizing
people in the community who are
presenting a very low risk to commit new
offenses journalist is where this began
and I think journalism is where the
sentence and so we hope that we can give
you the perspective that there this is a
human issue and it is it's so important
to remember that